battle of the peralta's tonight here at
comerica park willie peralta will be
pitching in his 15th start of the season
for the tigers he did not factor in a
decision a week ago tuesday at
pittsburgh
and uh willie's facing his former team
swings and misses
and the night starts with willie
peralta's strikeout of milwaukee's
leadoff man
well there's there's a willy's bread and
butter pitch when he's ahead in the
count
fly ball softly into right field
over and in toward right center reyes
makes the easy grab
two up and two down
ground ball left side that's jamerr
candelario's area and that's a 10 pitch
first inning
for woolly peralta freddie peralta
making start number 25 here tonight it's
been kind of a rough road for freddy's
is coming off the injured list he is
part of the big three for the brewers
with corbin burns and brandon woodruff
oh there's a nasty little breaking ball
that's in there
called strike three akil badu is
peralta's first strikeout victim of the
night
got him on three pitches nasty
and there's the swing and miss stuff
you're looking for partner yeah not many
of these uh
detroit tigers have ever seen freddie
both strikeouts coming on the slider
that's a good start for freddy
and the 2-2 swung on it missed hey how
about that start
three up three down three k's
for freddy peralta
looking like his old self good start to
the night no score second inning both
pitchers out of the gate sharp like the
first
willie peralta starts the second out
with a strikeout to a pitch
how about this narvaez just serves one
into center field to base head just a
thing of beauty right there check it out
that might have been the splitter
maybe slider it's hard to tell pretty
good pitch but even a better job of
swinging it back peralta works third
base side to 2-0
swinging a line drive left center field
over and in badou to make the catch
sizzling line drive but dude makes a
nice running catch into the left center
field gap
bogelbach is out number three
although
and he jumps on the first pitch a liner
to left yelich is there for out number
two
i think that ball's hit hard
deep right center field and there to
make the play garcia
nico goodram lines out to deep right
center back to back line drive outs
willie ferrante here in the third
against lorenzo kane colton wong and
eduardo escobar
on the backhand jonathan scope
one out here in the milwaukee third
in the air
to center field
wong's gonna tag on his way to second
the throw is a little tardy
and wong beats it there here's the two
one
ripped right at jonathan scope
position a for jonathan scope and he
robs christian yelich of extra early and
easy outs
and it's got his pitch count very good
shape 22 pitches
there's a cold strike three victor reyes
he's got it going freddy peralta my
goodness 4ks already ball just coming
out of his hand differently
so much differently than it did his
first two starts fourth inning no score
garcia gets on top of one a base hit to
right so there have been some hard-hit
balls in this game
yell it's lined out to end the third
inning with a runner at second now
garcia
the 2-2
fastball got him oh home plate umpire
doug eddings had to consider it for a
moment
and then he properly rings up urrias
that was a perfect pitch four k's for
peralta and narvaez wants that breaking
ball
got him again same spot that's nasty
good bite to it going straight down gets
him on the curve ball again one two
pitch got him
freddie peralta
what a start back-to-back case
three up three down fourth inning
peralta with six strikeouts through four
just strikes out a future hall of famer
having a good day second time through
the order faces jamer candelario the
only man who's reached base safely
against peralta
the 2-1 that's a broken bad blooper it's
a beauty that's a beautiful weight
i'm gonna put on the brakes that's the
first hit of the night for detroit
awesome dustin garneau the two catchers
bouncing ball got a chance to turn it
escobar to one over to first and a
double play boy how sweet was that by
colton wong my goodness
and check out how quickly wong is able
to get that ball out of the glove and on
its way to first to turn the double play
wow that's a rare one peralta is not a
ground ball pitcher
so to get a ground ball double play as a
bonus
and a swing and a miss he put it right
by him
seven k's for fastball freddy
up to 96 for peralta he kind of cruises
93-94
swinging to miss
splitter up and away and yell at chased
and now eight in a row retired by willie
peralta the 2-2
fastball got him at the top of the
strike zone willie peralta is rolling
maybe
he has just cruised to the first six
innings and freddie peralta continues on
here in the bottom of the sixth inning
do2 swinging a fly ball softly into
center field kane charging and had to
play it on a little short hop as he
charged scooped
got it into second so two bloop hits for
the tigers
[Music]
swing at a miss he struck him out
number eight for freddie peralta came
all the way back he was down in the
count 2-0 three consecutive pitches to
strike him out here's a 2-2
got him
went upstairs again this time a little
more over the plate
and picks up strikeout number nine as
everybody was sort of taking cover and
two of us
were sort of toughing it out and then
all of a sudden only one of us was
toughing it out because one of us got
out of our chair well indicating
i couldn't even think i couldn't cope
focus i couldn't do anything and so i
just had to even sell it he just had to
get out of there
right right behind the other guy the
bigger guy and then
who took the brunt of the storm
all right we're ready we're ready for
baseball
in downtown detroit let's rejoin
matt shepard and jack morris by the way
folks keats then quickly came up here
for cover and i don't blame him one bit
all right we resume
after an hour and 48 minute rain delay
and a first pitch swing
looping to left field and in for a base
hit omar narvaez
begins the seventh with a lead off
single and a huge ear to ear smile and
then they sit for almost two hours and
it's got to be hard ground ball to short
on the backhand good room there's one
there's two
well nico had a little trouble getting
it out of his glove but he makes a good
solid throw good throw right over to
willy and willie makes a good pivot and
good accurate throw to first plenty of
time when the bottom of the ninth inning
zeros across the board for both teams
scoreless in the bottom of the ninth the
3-2
lost him change-up bases are loaded
winning run at third base one out 0-2
pitch got him struck him out on a slider
josh hayder
most of the time it is just all about
throwing strikes for josh
fastball fastball slider to get him one
two pitch and he struck him out
98 mile an hour chatterjees
loads the bases for christian yelich
this is a double play candidate because
he hit so many balls on the ground
here's the 3-1
ground ball to second
there's one the relay
time
second double play turn tonight and they
get perhaps
the brewers most dangerous hitter
wow
take a deep breath
eric hill will be coming to plate
here it is
swinging away right center field a
bullet there for reyes
rounding third on his way home you bet
tigers win it in walk off fashion thanks
to derrick hill
i don't need no steak and bunt
well and look who's carrying the water
this
jug
quite another game
another
crazy crazy game